quito sufre los mayores niveles de agua
a causa del invierno registrado desde el
año 2013 un aluvión se produjo en el
sector residencial conocido como la
gasca durante la noche de este lunes las
cifras continúan incrementándose con 100
uniformes en el servicio nacional de
gestión de riesgo en ecuador mientras
que las imágenes muestran los daños que
han tenido que vivir los habitantes de
un sector residencial al norte de quito
y se experimentan en distintas partes de
la ciudad troncos casas colapsadas y
piedras corrieron por las calles a causa
de la fuerza de aguas en una zona
considerada de alto riesgo desde hace 40
años la ciudad amaneció colapsada y la
imagen que más se repite son personas
caminando por las principales vías con
el cuerpo de rescates barro y rastros de
fuertes lluvias que hay que han
experimentado la ciudad en los últimos
días el colapso del embalse en una
quebrada al norte la ciudad fue la causa
del aluvión según las autoridades que
arrastró con fuerza todo a su paso el
municipio de quito activo centros de
acopio para recibir donaciones ropa para
abrigarse artículos sanitarios de
alimentos no perecederos desde el año
2017 hasta el año 2020 ecuador ha
enfrentado desastres naturales
inundaciones y deslizamientos sin contar
una ley de gestión de riesgos a nivel
nacional 21 de los 221 cantones
ecuatorianos ya registran inundaciones
colapsos por lluvias producidas en el
invierno paralelamente ya se produce la
convocatoria de la colaboración
internacional para apoyar así a las
familias afectadas